day two of the Munich conference one of
the main speakers US Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo he began by contradicting a
thesis put forward the day before by
German President Frank father Steinmeier
the United States rejects the
international community end of quote
I'm here this morning to tell you the
facts I'm happy to report that the death
of the transatlantic alliance is grossly
over exaggerated that may be but the
mornings other main speaker was not so
sure French president Emmanuel McConnell
said Europe must become more independent
of the US if we have no freedom to act
then we have no credibility in foreign
policy and we can't be a junior partner
to the United States of America McKown
and Pompeyo also disagreed over one of
the main themes of this year's
conference that the West is losing
global influence when I look at the
world as it's being shaped and that's
the theme of your conference this year
there is indeed weakening of the West it
looks you don't this idea of West
lessness as the core theme for this
year's conference and I'm sure to there
are many of you who would call yourself
here realists well let me give you an
idea of what's real the West is winning
15 years ago we thought that our values
were universal that we were going to
dominate the world in the long term that
we were dominant in terms of Technology
military and so on and then I look at
the horizon of 10 to 15 years we are
going to be increasingly pushed by other
agendas and other values the free West
has a far brighter future than a liberal
alternatives were winning and we're
doing it together it was left in NATO
secretary-general Jens Stoltenberg to
try and smooth over the continuing
transatlantic tensions Europe and North
America are indispensable partners two
sides of the same coin so when we stand
together we can compete with confidence
protect our interests and defend our
values
Thank You DW correspondent teri Schultz
is covering the conference forest from
Munich she joins us now for more in fact
teri you're doing more than just
covering the conference you're actually
moderating one of the panels this
morning the Pompey panel you were
moderating that discussion what was your
biggest takeaway Carl I think the thing
that struck me the most was how
different this Pompeo speech was from
those we've seen in Brussels or the
comments that President Trump makes
about the European Union you know
normally they're all about America first
America leading and in this case as you
heard secretary Pompeo said we're a team
and we are winning we're doing it
together we're winning collectively and
this is something I haven't heard from
Secretary of Pompeo before so it was
very interesting to get the sense that
he and a way is trying to talk the
Europeans back into wanting to be
transatlantic partners after the
administration has done so much to turn
them away on the other hand many
European leaders have a completely
different message saying the West is
weakening French President Emmanuel
macron was one of those today he says he
wants Europe to do more without the
United States in fact we asked Germany's
foreign minister Heiko Maas for his
thoughts on the matter
let's take a listen we will accept the
invitation to the strategic dialogue we
believe that we first need to decide
within Europe how to meet the increased
demands in the future we will have to do
more for our security but I think it
would be a mistake to pit Europe against
the US we're in a security alliance that
works NATO but it needs reform and we're
discussing that now we want to bolster
the European side of NATO and to do that
we first need to reach consensus in
Europe the dialogue that Emmanuel macron
has proposed
can play a significant role in this
that's why we will take part so Terry it
looks like mas not ready to give up on
the United States yet or even on NATO
even though there have been these
increased tensions with Europe that's
right every European leader acknowledges
that there is no
replacement for NATO as the security
guarantor for Europe even those
Europeans and they are very few I would
have to say who talk about an EU army
always say that NATO will remain the
chief source of security for all
European countries so it's not
surprising to hear that from European
leaders what's more interesting is that
Europeans are finally picking up the
message that the US has pushed on them
for so long that they need to be more
self-sufficient and so president Makran
sees an opening for himself now
especially with the departure of Britain
from the European Union and he is
definitely trying to position himself as
both a disrupter to try to get Europeans
to to do more to defend themselves and
to position himself at them as the the
head of that movement so it's going to
be very interesting to watch the French
leaders moves as he tries to establish
himself in this position yeah that's a
message we've been hearing from Emmanuel
macron for some time teri Schultz thank
you so much reporting for us from Munich